well I'm delighted to welcome you to the
2012 annual Robert H Ludwick's
lecture in ethics and public policy this
year as Nicholas just said in fact today
on this very day we celebrated or
remember the 22nd anniversary of Bob's
death it's a special occasion therefore
for many of us and we're particularly
courses they have with us Bob's mother
mrs. Gertrude litter wits and his sister
Laurie litter wits and some friends of
his and the family some of us here knew
Bob Linda wits and we're glad for the
occasion to remember and honor him today
the new Bob is a remarkable man who came
to Yale Divinity School while he was
still a student at Columbia Law School
he was one of the world's genuine
seekers he wanted in particular to for
some questions that crossed disciplines
and that bridged religious traditions
and diverse cultures he was brilliant
creative in multiple ways as a
storyteller an adventurer a craftsman a
businessman and a scholar he was a deep
thinker troubled by what he considered
deficiencies in American educational
structures in convinced that
interdiscipline interdisciplinary
approaches are essential to contemporary
learning and the guidance of
contemporary society so when he was
diagnosed with cancer while still a
student here at Yale he established a
charitable trust whose aim would be to
support interdisciplinary research
teaching and scholarship in ethics and
social policy this lecture series
represents some of the fruits of his
concerns and that's what your years go
by I think
we here at Yale appreciate more and more
the wisdom of Bob's insights and the
values of his actions thank you let me
tell you I'm delighted to be here and I
want first of all to thank the little
it's family for their sponsorship of
this of this lecture which means a great
deal to me and is a great honor and I'm
really delighted to be here I I also
would like to thank the students the epe
students who who read my book and took
part in the meet the author series I'd
like to thank professor Sam baños I'd
like to thank Erika de Brown Debruyne
Kelly Ann Farnham and I'd like to thank
professor Farley for for starting
today's events I proposed today to talk
a little bit to take what was what
looked like Europe's biggest problem a
few years ago and Link it to what looks
like Europe's biggest problem today that
is when I started working on immigration
it appeared that the failure in Europe
to create a multi-ethnic multicultural
society would was was the continents
most serious problem I think it still
may be the continents most serious
long-term problem nonetheless it's a
problem that's been driven out of the
news to some degree by the economic
emergency following the financial crash
of 2008 I have a sense and I've had a
sense for a while that these crises are
related most obviously they're related
they are demographic problems Europe's
need for unprecedented mass emigration
and the and the precariousness of its
states state budgets these are both the
function of demographic change of
populations that are shrinking not
reproducing themselves aging you have a
smaller workforce and
mass immigration and budgetary
shortfalls are two pretty inevitable
results of that both though and here's
the second thing that I'd like to focus
on a lot today
both are problems of hidden costs and
shortly after my book was published in
England an interviewer on the radio
there spoke to me to describe my book as
the case against immigration now I
reject that description but I do think I
do see what he was getting at if if the
book concerns anything it's that
immigration has costs and benefits the
benefits tend to be immediate and
measurable the costs tend to be
intangible complicated and pushed back
to the future
they arose they involve things like the
erosion of democracy the the drift away
from certain rights the redefinition of
the relations between states and peoples
and and these are what we've these
things that we've come to call in the
years since the finance crisis the
things that we've come to call off
balance sheet liabilities so this
afternoon I hope to make a few
observations about both problems first
I'll talk about immigration and
multi-ethnic societies and then I'll
shift suddenly and jarringly to a
discussion of the euro and I'll try to
tie both those things together and since
tying them together is something that I
would appreciate your help in thinking
about then we can open the floor and
sort of talk about this a little bit now
people in general who are interested in
in immigration questions tend to be
Manicheans
they may view immigration and all
migration as an as a way either as a way
to proclaim that we should all love each
other more or as a way to say that the
world is going to hell in a handbasket
and although my book does have a simple
theme that that you cannot have the same
Europe with different people
I I do not think it's a manichaean
approach i'm i i'd i have never intended
to lecture europeans on what sort of
society they ought to create under
conditions of globalization's i'd rather
try to write from a critical distance
and to ask what kind of europe is going
to result from decades of of mass
emigration and whether that kind of
europe is going to be acceptable to
europeans now if you take this critical
distance i think that you can see a
typology at work in the immigration
problems of all european countries
native Europeans are proud of their
diversity immigrants to Europe are proud
of their diversity both blame the
problems of integration the problems
that immigrants have with natives and
vice-versa
both blame these problems on particular
parochial things in in in individual
countries like if only such-and-such a
minister hadn't been so lenient with
asylum applications when he was you know
when he was in power or if only this
Home Secretary hadn't been so harsh he
wouldn't have created such resentment
among immigrant populations or if only
we've got those hard-working immigrants
from country X instead of the you know
the delinquent ones from country Y or if
only we hadn't joined the the European
Union or if only we'd stayed out of the
Iraq war there wouldn't have been so
much resentment and the impression left
is that the immigration population in
Europe is a a diverse phenomenon and the
product of local accidents but I think
that it's not structurally Europe's
immigration situation is not
particularly diverse even if the people
and the countries involved in it are and
I think if you can if you understand how
immigration Islam and native European
cultures interact
in any Western European country you have
a kind of a rough-and-ready prediction
of how they're going to react in in most
other ones no matter what that country's
national character no matter what matter
whether it conquered an empire no matter
what its role in world war two its
relationship to fascism its role in the
Iraq coalition and no matter where it's
Muslim immigrants come from you get the
same you get roughly the same arguments
about the veiling of women about
anti-semitism about whether certain
groups foster terrorism these are
problems in every European country and
the solutions that people try to come up
with have a certain family resemblance
there are certain quirks among European
immigrant issues I mean during the Iraq
war for instance I recall that the
Muslim population of Sweden which
contains a large number of Iraqi Kurds
was arguably more pro-american than the
country at large Britain differs from
continental countries in that its
foreign policy rather than gender
relations that is the main sticking
point between Muslims and non non
Muslims France differs from other
countries in not only in that it's had
recent riots but also that it's the only
country that's really winning a
significant number of immigrants over to
what you might think of as an
american-style patriotism patriotism but
in its broad outline the these problems
of immigration integration and the
multicultural society are the same in
all Western European countries all that
all countries have the same ageing
shrinking populations the same need for
unskilled labour all countries make the
same diagnosis of their immigration
challenges and they put forward the same
economic and social policies and once we
take this perspective I think it's
easier to address immigration as a basic
basic transaction that has
which are mostly upfront and costs which
evolve which arrived mostly over the
long haul now a straightforward way of
making this cost-benefit analysis I
think is the one done by the Oxford
demographer David Coleman Coleman has
urged that when we tally up the economic
impact of immigration we also consider
and he says quote the total costs of the
integration process and of the
associated immigration and race
relations businesses the costs of
meeting the special education health and
housing needs of immigrants the net
effects upon the education of ordinary
children in immigrant areas the
permanent need to regenerate urban areas
of immigrant settlement instead of
demolishing them issues of crime in
public order and the multiplier effect
on future immigration I would say if
anything that that is too narrow a
definition of the of the consequences of
of immigration but that last item about
the multiplier effective of immigration
does approach the main hidden cost of
your of immigration that Europeans have
only recently begun to understand and
that is that a commitment to mass
immigration means a commitment to long
term mass immigration and that's and if
you understand that you can understand
why immigration has continued through
the decades in Europe even though public
opinion in Europe has been steadily and
overwhelmingly against it and I would
say that this is one of them this has
been a very dangerous thing for
democracy in Europe that you've had this
overwhelmingly unpopular phenomenon
which has done nothing but increase now
why should this be why should Europe
have so much decade after decade of mass
immigration well accounts of the
benefits of immigration often describe
the jobs that immigrants take as jobs no
European wants now what's really meant
is jobs no European wants at a
particular wage
recently the
Gration specialist Phillip Martin of the
University of california-davis
drew a very interesting parallel between
today's migrants and settlers of
European colonies in the 18th century
back then
migrants paid the cost of their
resettlement through an indenture you
know how that works they promised a
given number of years of labor to the
landowner who fronted their voyage and
Martin speculated that perhaps today's
immigrants pay an updated kind of
indenture in the form of Rights living
as they often do in an ambiguous legal
status that condemns them to only the
lowest jobs and very few legal
protections now if there really are jobs
that Europeans won't do at any price
this indenture is a big part of what
natives believe they are getting out of
immigration and and it does resemble the
situation in the United States we often
hear people say they prefer legal to
illegal immigration but in fact it's the
illegal immigrants who are the real
bargain for the society as a whole they
are the people who work at wages that
make possible the you know 99-cent
burgers at on the value menu down at the
at the fast food shop now whether or not
this indenture is fair well it depends
on the context in which you view it on
one hand the arrangement is corrosive
its corrosive of democracy and
fellow-feeling because it creates two
tiers of Rights in the in the
destination country on the other hand
the immigrants themselves are not likely
to complain they are doing better than
they would have done in their native
countries but there's a hitch to this
because the benefits of this indenture
they accrue to to immigrants new
countries to the to the countries where
the immigrants go only so long as the
immigrants are illegal and transitional
and immigrants don't stay that way
forever
as soon as immigrants are legally and
socially assimilated in a way that
society professed
- warts they acquire all sorts of rights
and expectations they become in the case
of Europe they become Europeans who then
by definition won't do the jobs that no
European wants and then you need a whole
new batch of immigrants so the moment
and this is a terrible paradox at the
moment immigration is successful
socially the main economic reason that
society thinks it needs immigrants
vanishes and at that point in order to
to ensure that these jobs nobody wants
gets done you have another cycle of
recruitment and so the faster and more
thoroughly immigrants adapt to your
society the more immigrants you need
another way to look at this I would say
is is social rather than economic and
you will take you to the same conclusion
and that is the same concluding that
once immigration becomes your policy it
becomes a self-perpetuating policy look
at diversity ok everyone everyone
praises diversity but but but where
diversity is the result of an
immigration there is a similar illogic
if diversity enriches and strengthens
nations as much as people claim why
would any nation want its immigrants to
integrate into the broader society
because in fact that would be drawing
down this fund of diversity which is so
valuable and yet
we know people immigrate we couldn't
stop them from integrating even if we
wanted to and what a grim life they
would have if they did not so we know
that immigrants integrate and if
diversity is indeed army our need we
need to replace that replenish that
disappearing diversity with more
immigration every generation that supply
of new churning must be kept on tap and
so you have a and this is the paradox
that I'm talking about is that Europe
has become a country in which
large-scale immigration is
both supposed to make countries
different through diversity and supposed
to leave them the same through
integration now what does this
ultimately mean it means that Europe is
becoming a society on the American model
it's becoming a nation of immigrants you
might assume that this is like just an
empty cliche or a historical fact you
know all our parents came from other
countries America is a nation of
immigrants and I used to think that
myself but it's but it's not an empty
empty cliche it's a it's a profound
ethos to be a to be a nation of
immigrants a nation of immigrants is not
just a nation that gets foreigners or is
good at giving a foreigners a nice place
to stay
a nation of immigrants is a country that
is willing to be changed by foreigners
and our country it's a it's a country
that has consented to undergoing a
permanent demographic revolution and
that that is what our country is but
I've got to tell you that sounds a lot
better to us than it does to Europeans
they have always considered the American
Americanization of their continent which
has been proceeding not just via
immigration but also via television and
advertising and American corporations
very visibly for the last half-century
they've always considered this
Americanization a kind of a Faustian
bargain all the stuff that Europeans
have traditionally admired about America
the dynamism the energy the
unpredictability the lack of hangups the
freedom from class Europeans are going
to get that but all the things that
Europeans have traditionally disliked
about the United States the impermanence
the people running around who are
indifferent to what their grandparents
did and their indifference to whether
they're the rules under which their
children
who determines those rules all that
impermanence and transients that
Europeans associate with America they're
going to get that too and and I I think
that most Europeans do not realize even
now that they have embarked on this
journey that America continues to take
they they do not necessarily they have
not necessarily accepted that it's
permanent and they don't feel they've
consented to it and that's a very big
that is the biggest of the hidden costs
of of immigration
now with that here comes my sudden turn
with that I would like to turn to the
economy and specifically the the crisis
of the Euro mass migration as they say
is one symptom of a rapidly globalizing
world the European Union's experiment in
multinational government or more
appropriately governance and monetary
union is another such experiment like
mass emigration the consolidation of the
European Union has its upsides and its
downsides and just as with my migration
while the upsides tend to be immediately
evident the downsides emerge over time
I'm afraid that the downside of the
European crisis may involve serious
damage to the democracies of various
European countries and may involve in
fact an exit from democracy as newspaper
readers know the European Union's shared
currency the euro is in crisis the euro
created a problem it tethered these
dynamic not particularly creditworthy
economies like Ireland and Spain
together with one especially sluggish
and predictable economy which was
Germany as it used to exist which was
back in the 90s
sort of struggling under the weight of
reunification the euro took a set of
rules that were appropriate for a bunch
of old people or nuns and applied them
to a bunch of you know teenagers or some
emerging
you know emerging economies let us say
so the result in the best of cases as in
Spain or Ireland was a a housing boom
that was even more excessive than that
of the United States but without the
reserve currency which has given us a
great deal of flexibility and in in in
getting out of it in the worst of cases
where this this boom economy combined
with actual political corruption as in
Greece well then the money didn't go
even go into anything so real as as real
estate but in in Greece that went into
the replacement of Greece's native
economy with an import economy and and
and an economy that ran pretty much on
on tourism now in but in both cases
these struggling countries have been
deprived via Europe of the main
instrument that countries have
traditionally used to dig their way out
of financial messes and that is
devaluation the economists who said that
you can't unite countries in a single
currency unless you unite them under a
single central government they have been
proved right so as we so how did we get
here as we contemplate this
macroeconomic storm that some passing
through Europe we should bear in mind
that it's a storm that the the builders
of the European Union knew would arrive
the designers of the euro understood
Rahm Emmanuel's philosophy about not
letting a crisis go to waste
I mean jean monet who has claimed to be
one of the handful of the the founding
fathers of the euro said you're
we'll be forged in crises and it will be
the some of the solutions bought 2ds
brought to these crises so when the
French statesman Jacques de lor laid out
his plan for the euro in the late 1990s
you know he drew a clear trajectory he
said a common market had made possible a
common currency and a common currency
would make possible a common government
but you have to ask yourself how would
that happen and and why if contrary to
what history has taught it proved
possible to have a currency that was not
under the control of any one state well
then I mean if this worked fine if the
Euro worked fine then there would be no
reason to change the existing governing
Arrangements institutional change of the
sort that the euros founders sought
could result only from the currencies
getting into trouble
so I you know you can see that economic
this economic crisis kind of looks like
the and accidentally on purpose kind of
pretext for a consolidation of power in
Brussels and so the European Union had
at its start as I say has from its start
from it front from its start it has
brought us to that point now I don't
think the I don't think the idea that
Europe has grown less democratic as a
result of the financial crisis should be
controversial but in case it is I would
like to offer a few different ways of
measuring it and the first is the
increasing prominence of so-called
fiscal Union in the in the list of
solutions to the crisis fiscal union
means the harmonization at the very
least the mixing in increasingly as it's
talked about in the mixing of state
budgets what it basically means is
having prudent countries or credit
surplus
cover the debts of credit deficit
countries and this sounds good you know
it sounds like International Cooperation
it sounds like a way of taking a solvent
country like Germany and putting it
together with an insolvent country like
Greece and getting to solvent countries
instead of one the problem is that
there's little agreement between
northern and southern countries about
how this will happen for Germany fiscal
union basically means sending German
fiscal policemen to impose austerity on
Mediterranean governments for southern
European countries fiscal union means
getting helped out by transfer payments
from northern Europe which are not going
to come in short northern countries want
a euro government and southern countries
want a euro bond they want a common
European financial instrument however it
happens this is a crucial step in
building the EU one of these two things
is going to happen it's the moment the
founders of Europe were waiting for it
but but what it means is a removal of
budget authority from national
parliaments not just in crisis times but
in ordinary times and an entity that is
without control of a budget is most of
us would say not a state so fiscal Union
however you arrive at it does mean
disbanding the countries that make up
the EU and that's not the way it was
sold and you can see you can see why
people are going into the streets and in
some of these countries particularly in
Greece now the second way you might see
this is that you can see that the the
second way you see a retreat from
democracy is through the replacement of
elected leaders with unelected ones
increasingly over the past winter you
know you've seen this this progression
the first example is in Italy the way
Silvio
Mosconi was removed from power in the
fall you know like him or not like his
ways with women or not he was the
democratically elected Prime Minister of
Italy enjoying full constitutional
legitimacy I think it's worth adding
that as an economic matter although he
didn't do too much right in terms of
fiscal policy he didn't do that much
wrong either Italy has very low deficits
and its debt is roughly where it was
when Berlusconi came to power in 1994
the only the only bad thing is that
Italy was in a terrible mess in 1994
it's pretty much in the same terrible
mess now what Berlusconi did wrong is
that he confounded the --use attempts to
use the European Central Bank to resolve
Italy's crisis late last summer when the
ECB when the European Central Bank
bought Italian state debt to drive
Italy's interest rates down to
sustainable sustainable levels
Berlusconi agreed to structural reforms
and he then reneged on those reforms now
this was a terrible thing to do for
which Berlusconi ought to have been held
accountable by the Italian voting public
but instead he was held accountable by
Germany and France German Chancellor
Angela Merkel spoke to the Italian
president who's generally a figure
figurehead but became an acting head of
state in in this case Giorgio Napolitano
is his name who appointed Mario Monti
a prominent economist senator for life
he's probably the the most famous person
to hold that title since General
Pinochet but but and he put and then
presented Monti to Italians as their
take it or leave it
next premier now Monty is a is a is a
first-rate economist he's a gifted
politician as far as I know he's a he's
a perfectly honest politician
but I think that the peripheral question
of whether Monty is a better guy than
Berlusconi or whether you trust him more
than Berlusconi should not distract us
from the primary question which is that
Italy had a democratically elected
government last summer and now it has a
semi democratic government now at about
the same time that Italy's the the
Berlusconi was being replaced
Greece's premier George Papandreou was
was being removed now even with a big
right down of its debt it's likely that
Greece owes more money than it can
reasonably hope to repay if this latest
right down plan works absolutely
perfectly the estimates are that Greece
will still owe 120 percent of its GDP
and in ten years from now and that might
be that very well might be unsustainable
in early November Europe's leaders
presented Papandreou with a plan to stop
the country's finance crisis Papandreou
it's important to note did not say no
but he did say that he would like to ask
his country for permission through a
referendum on a decision that's going to
bind them actually for generations at
that point the European Union's leaders
not its duly constituted leaders but
Nicolas Sarkozy and angle Americo again
speaking as individual heads of
individual nations they offered Greece
the choice between remaining in the
eurozone and replacing Papandreou with
some kind of more acceptable governor
and that's how we got Lucas Papademos as
president of Greece there was a coda to
that episode it's about a month ago and
it comes out of the fact that Greece is
supposed to have elections next month
about a month ago Germany's Finance
Minister Wolfgang schäuble suggested on
a German radio show that Greece
postponed its elections which are do you
know next month as I say
in order that a technocratic government
along the lines of Italy be allowed to
carry out the reforms so given the this
tendency towards semi democratic
governments I think it is not surprising
that the project of building the EU no
longer commands anything like the
popular support that it had during the
Cold War you know the II support for the
EU has had its ups and downs I would say
in the 1950s there was a lot of
skepticism about handing over power I
would say that that roughly between the
the entry of Britain into the EU in the
mid 70s and the Maastricht Treaty in the
1990s there was a genuine legitimacy
there was a genuine will on the part of
of the leaders of other nations to hand
over sovereignty but I think that that
has been absent for at least the last
seven years in in 2005 the EU asked its
citizens to approve the transfer of a
large amount of political power
explicitly from the national governments
to Brussels through a constitutional
referendum and the repudiation of
European publics was was decisive I mean
the French this was the most intense
political discussion the Frant a French
had had since 1968 possibly since the
war and they voted against further
consolidation of European power by 55
percent the Dutch voted against it by
almost 2 to 1 and after that Europe
cancelled all the remaining referenda
and yet now this is where I'm going to
tie it into immigration and yet the none
of this has done anything to [ __ ] the
moving forward of the European project
we spoke you know we spoke earlier about
how immigration creates the need for
immigration well in the much in much the
same way the European Union creates the
need for more Europe
Union this is sort of like it sort of
reminds me of the Cat in the Hat you
know the European Union is an
institution that creates problems that
only it can solve and and and I think
that most even most opponents of the
Euro see that this is a sort of that the
dynamic is moving away from the nations
and towards more centralization of power
in Europe last fall I was in in Munich I
was I was I spoke to Peter gavel ER he's
a politician in the Christian social
Union and he had he has a reputation of
being maybe the the most anti euro
politician in in Germany and yet he said
he thought it would be very hard for for
Germany to get out of the euro easy you
know he said he thought Germany should
never have gone into the euro but then
when I asked him well should it then
pull out he said I don't know and I said
well isn't that an inconsistency he said
no and he quoted some proper - proverb
to me he said just because you can make
a fish soup out of an aquarium does not
mean you can make an aquarium out of a
fish soup so now what what ties these
two things together I you know I I don't
usually use this kind of vocabulary when
I talk about politics but I think that
the euro crisis and the immigration
crisis are both members of a family of
crises of democratic capitalism the euro
crisis and the immigration crisis they
both have something in common with
various banking crises and Minar the
most extraordinary interpretations i've
read over the past few years of what's
going on is is by the german sociologist
wolfgang strike who runs a Max Planck
Institute in Cologne and while he's a
sociologist he's also an economic
thinker I think of great subtlety now in
in two recent articles in the new left
review he laid out an interesting thesis
that which is that in a free-market
democracy
you have a conflict between two ways of
allocating goods you know there's market
allocation and there's political
allocation the broadest possible way of
describing the consequences is to say
that the politicians who get elected are
usually the ones who most credibly offer
a free lunch
now I'm not usually someone who finds
himself bobbing his head up and down in
agreement as I read the new left review
I can assure you but one of the things I
do like about strike is his willingness
to to question certain social democratic
shibboleths for instance he admits that
the high wages of the late labor union
heyday were he doesn't say they're a
bubble but he does say this he says
government's commitment to full
employment together with a growing
welfare state protected trade unions
from potential employment losses caused
by wage settlements in excess of
productivity growth what he's trying to
say is labor unions were able to get
through political muscle more than they
could have got in the open economy and
what basically happened is you had to
offer people both what they could get
through the economy and what they could
get through politics you basically
needed to win it to win an election
you needed to be able to give people you
know although this is me saying that's
not strike you you needed to be able to
give people a dollar 50 worth of
services for a dollar worth of taxes the
world
straik decide describes is a world in
which no government can long stay in
power unless it offers people this sort
of increment which we didn't call
something for nothing when trade union
demands began to break business in in in
the 1970s government stepped in with a
solution it increased let's say in the
60s
70s government stepped in to offer
various welfare state entitlements in
exchange for trade union moderation when
these entitlements themselves began to
burden the state in the 1970s
governments then tried to inflate them
away when inflation slowed down the
economy in the early in late 1970s and
early 1980s the government fixed that
problem but only by running huge
deficits and when big deficits began to
scare markets governments paid them off
but at the same time they did so they
deregulated banking allowing voters to
replace public with private debt and the
final stage is what we saw in the vote
on the Troubled Asset Relief Rule Relief
Program in 2008 where democratic states
turned into what straight calls quote
debt collecting agencies on behalf of a
global oligarchy of investors compared
to which see right mills as power elite
appears a shining example of liberal
pluralism but I you know I think that we
might all find something to disagree
with politically there but but but I
think that his basic point that
inflation public debt and then private
debt all made it possible to quote
introduce resources into the
distributional conflicts of the time
that had not yet been produced enabling
governments to draw on future resources
in addition to those already on hand I
think we can agree that that's sort of
what has happened to us and I think it's
what happened to Europe and I think that
the you know a lot of the policies I
think of recent decades have been not
rescues but false rescues with the
benefit of hindsight I would say that
mass immigration for all its benefits
belongs to this family of false rescues
that straight describes the positive
jolt to the economy from cheap wages was
recognized very quickly and to some
extent it continues this is not a dead
loss but the high cost of immigrating
integrating immigrants a cost not just
in money but in
in rights and disrupted habits that's
something that would not come due until
later so probably if you looked
carefully at immigration five years ago
you might have seen the finance crisis
coming there as in banking Democratic
sentiment called for one thing which was
a curtailment of immigration while
financial sentiment called for another
which was a continuum continuation of
immigration immigration - draws on
future resources to solve present-day
distributional conflicts if - belongs to
this policy idea this family of policy
ideas in which the benefits are obvious
but the costs are off-balance-sheet
to use an expression that's become
familiar and that the Morrises cross a
certain threshold of income which is
quite low income of argentina and
actually survive we never fall back so
there is a contradiction here which is
that the outcome does not correspond to
what we would expect given the
fundamental weakness that you identify
and if that is true there may be good
reasons to think about
then we may also push the analogy to
your other immigration maybe we could
say that well there is perhaps the way
in which you can get to actually know
the kind of issues this is why you Scott
is not it is the parties in a sense that
electron Eastern insofar as the parties
give the confidence to Prime Minister
Monti you can have a fully democratic
procedure however it is not unusual and
it is not necessarily external
intervention that you had parties
accepting this bargain but if you look
at prior your very big crisis in Europe
see the transition from the fourth to
the fifth French Republic that is
creating political parties accepted in a
sense to coalesce around in an unelected
or not directly legitimate leader
precisely to overcome the crisis i we
observe ok well that's really I mean
that's enough to talk about for the next
hour ok on democracy you know I'm not
sure yeah I'm not sure I buy these hard
and fast rule
about democracy because I think you know
that we used to here you know before the
Iraq war that you know no two countries
of where the MacDonalds have ever gone
to war with each other no two
democracies have ever gone to war with
each other and I think that that's a
that can be very ilusory because I think
that when countries go to war with one
another they usually before that they
shift out of being a democracy I think I
don't know what the what the income what
the per capita income is for for for
losing you know the the threshold you're
talking to is but I think that if it
were inflation adjusted I think you'd
find that a lot of countries probably
went out of democracy you know between
the French Third Republic and the early
part of the of the 20th century
including France you know but so I'm not
I I I'm not comfortable that that I I'm
not as confident that we the the that
Europe's Europe's going to inevitably
stay at the same level of democracy your
last point about the about the in part
of the reason it has to do with your
last point about about the Democratic
deficit you're you're quite right that
the semi Democratic rather than non
democratic is is a is a the best
description of the Italian government I
mean Monti the problem with mati is that
he was appointed by the President and
that that may be that may be a
presidential power but it's an emergency
power it's not the kind of thing that
you expect to see in a in a
well-functioning democracy the vote by
the National Assembly is his obviously a
legitimate one he who's obviously chosen
prime minister by right the the the
legislature it's the way he got into you
know government does being named a
senator for life that is the I think the
the irregularity what you say about
what you say about how it's this is this
is um internal rather than external
pressure I think is a good is a good
point there are you know a lot of these
European countries and there's a kind of
an original sin in the way some of these
European nation states went into the
European Union I think that a lot of
these countries including including
Italy Italy under protein was certainly
this way a lot of these countries
expected to get out of Europe cover for
making fiscal adjustments that they
didn't have the votes to make anyway
so basically they wanted to make cuts
they wanted to raise taxes they wanted
to close budget gaps but they didn't
think their people would let them do it
and they were able to go to their people
and say the European Union is forcing us
to do this and you know we're going to
be kicked out of the big league and so
it so I think that there was an ante
there was an anti-democratic impulse in
it I think as that that happened but the
question that you asked about whether
there's a more optimist you know this
question of is this a is this a problem
actually that I'm describing here of
democracy this idea that you need to get
you know you need to get five dollars in
benefits for every four dollars you pay
in taxes perhaps it is I mean to a
degree but I do think that a more
optimistic reading is possible for
instance I do not think that the United
States has you know although it's got
very similar fiscal position to the
worst countries in Europe I don't think
that my my analysis of the of the
immigration problem in Europe holds for
the United States because I don't think
that the that immigration to the United
States distorts the way our Constitution
works the way it does
there's the Constitution is the wrong
word the culture there's a certain
cultural capital that their societies
are built on and ours is built on a
different kind of of cultural capital
and that's what I was getting at when I
said that we are content to be changed
by new waves of people I don't know that
they are there as far as no no I
yeah you know you the first article I
did on immigration was in the 1990s mid
1990s I I did a piece for The Atlantic
Monthly I went to to Marseille I met
with some Algerian French people
running up a charity you know they they
gave mittens to people in Algeria they
were they were devout Muslims this was
before any of you know any of the this
9/11 happened or anything like that and
it was so they were much more open it
was a it was a nice time to to meet with
people back then but they said something
that I I never forget you know they said
well our parents came because the French
people needed factors of production and
they got people instead I've heard that
a lot of times since but as I've never
really been able to improve on that as a
description of what the what the problem
was as factors of production this
immigration of the early 60s was a big
success as people to share a society
with you know if people said you're
gonna save you know you're gonna save 50
song teams on the unit cost of labor per
hour but you're also going to have a
country that is one-quarter Muslim
forever you know I don't think for most
French people would have accepted that
deal but but they didn't think that
these people were going to stay they did
not they did not think of them that way
and that's what I guess I mean about
that's the sort of hidden cost I mean
that there's a dealing you now have to
deal with in a sense you've borrowed
from the future democracy I don't know
that you've borrowed economic resources
from the future
you borrowed political resources from
the future in exchange for rather
short-lived economic gains so I don't
think I don't think it's a long term I
don't think it's the long term economic
things they've been barred and I tend to
think that the price for I think the
price of immigration tends to be paid in
the form of a change of a change in in
in social structures and folk ways that
would otherwise be undesirable to most
yes
if the high-skilled are not reacting
yeah yeah you know you just said most
academics don't dare to compare Paula -
Paula tix and and and and in economics
oh don't dare to talk about but at the
same time journalists tend to it's this
it's sort of maybe the fearlessness that
comes with ignorance or something like
that but with that qualification I think
the the dynamic of high income the
dynamic of high skill immigration and
the dynamic of a low-skilled I think
they're they're they're different I mean
we and we live in a country where we
need we need both and I think that you
know probably the the the state of the
school system probably has a lot to do
with with the country's need for
high-skilled immigration and the the
state of the Democratic for graphic
pyramid probably has a lot to do with
the state of low skilled immigration but
I I think there is you know it's tough
to measure you know who we're talking
about when we talk about the competition
the native-born competition for
immigrant or first or such second
generation labor its Miami you know if
we take the let's say the National Front
in France which is not only a right-wing
party but also I think has a rather low
demographic profile I think you can see
the the stirrings of their discontent
with immigration very early even at a
time when you were relatively close to
full employment so the cultural factor
there is something totally real to it I
think it in in in in for certain for
certain Europeans of European background
it's a primary problem I think for other
Europeans it's it's maybe a way that
that an economic competition is
is dressed up as being something a
little more
ennoble and maybe that is what you what
you see now but I still I would not
expect to see such a high such a high
level of success for anti-european
parties and remember they're rising
they've risen in the last couple of
years it's kind of a mystery you know
for two reasons one you have the the the
economic crisis which is a diversion
from the problem of immigration and two
you've had a fall in structural
unemployment in a lot of these European
countries certainly France and and
Germany you know I mean Germany had five
million well let's let's focus on France
the French unemployment rate is lower
than it was ten years ago and yet the
the National Front is stronger so I
don't know but III see indications in
both directions that it's that that the
that the economic is a that the cultural
is a primary concern in the end that
it's a that it's a the way an economic
concern is dressed up yes yeah yeah
the welfare Europeans are very proud of
their welfare states this by five to
four exchanges that you brought up yeah
over the last fifteen years or so that
you've been covering has this European
German franco-german aversion towards
anglo-saxon unbridled plutocracy
intensified over the years it's funny
I'd say yes and no I yes they've
rethought their model a bit and if you
look at Germany if you look at the
German hospital system I mean it used to
be made up of all private rooms and
things now people are doubling up in
rooms I mean people there have
particularly in Germany actually if you
look at the 2003 reforms now the reform
that's called agenda 2010 and the hearts
for unemployment reform that was a
serious serious welfare state reform
went considerably beyond what we did in
1996 and a lot of people say that's sort
of the foundation on which a lot of the
solidity of the German economy is built
today so they've been cutting and they
even sort of you know now that their age
pyramid is unfavorable they're going to
have to cut further and I think they are
beginning to understand that actually
particularly in places like Italy where
you have a rapidly declining the the the
the actual workforce in the country is
declining in in absolute numbers which
means that the per capita cost of a
given sized welfare state is rising even
if you keep the state the same size you
know so yes they realise that that they
have to change but at the same time
they have not diminished one bit there
their sense that that our system is
barbaric you know I mean I it's very
rare that I meet a European who
expresses anything but mystification at
why anyone would have opposed the the
Obama health care reform you know what I
mean
there I mean they just look at you and
say like what is this about it is it's
it's an obvious question for them so you
know actuarially they're they they know
that they're in trouble
ideologically I think that they still
think that these are you know they still
think there ways best yes sir
assimilationist okay okay first
integration well yes traditionally there
have been a variety of of ways to
negotiate this gap between the the
mainstream culture of these European
countries and the culture of those who
come into it we were talking about it at
at lunch today you know the French have
for many many years had this for
centuries at this idea of C to eientei
you know one is equal and you know a
there's equal citizenship in everything
and the the the the the state owes equal
treatment to all its citizens but in
return the citizens owe it to the state
to make each other you know to become
like their fellow citizens so and that
is not really a novelty and and I
actually think it's not unrelated to the
fact that that the French I I mean it
might be repugnant to our anglo-saxon
sensibilities to have a central
government saying you know you're gonna
be like this this is the kind of citizen
you're gonna be you know you're gonna
read Moliere in the 8th grade and the
Rousseau and the 12th grade and that you
know but I think it has a lot to do with
the fact that France is the only I think
thus far the only country in Europe that
has been able to
provoke in or or reduce from from its
immigrants a sense of you know a sense
of this the the same sort of paint what
we in America would recognize as
patriotism you know I don't think it's a
majority of North African immigrants to
to to France who said hey you know laugh
halls might we you know but it's a it's
a sizable number and it's a it's enough
it's enough people that it that you have
to say France has been more successful
at this than than other countries I just
if I may just sort of throw out one idea
you know I mean I think that the this is
a big this French Republican seat want a
day is a is a is a powerful secular idea
most secular ideas are not that strong
they're not as strong as French or
American patriotism they're kind of like
you know I mean you in a lot of these
liberal democracy in Europe the the you
know the culture is well do it you want
you know that kind of thing it's there's
no anything and that's why I think in in
knows in those cultures the Netherlands
is one of them all right we're not going
to prescribe anything for you in those
cultures that in in those cultures I
think Islam is viewed as more of a
threat because Islam actually is a
religion in it and as such it offers
something that societies lack you know
it so so yes there's a difference I
think these differences between European
countries are closing I would have said
one of the biggest differences between
neighboring countries was between Sweden
and Denmark five years ago but you know
Sweden's becoming much less easy come
easy go and much more like what they
call the right-wing when they looked at
Denmark five years ago now for you next
yeah
yeah well you know what if we can just
sort of step back from beating around
the bush a little bit you know we talked
about how great assimilation has worked
in this country and it has you know I
mean we've all become part of the same
culture but I think most of us in this
room have the religion of our mother's
mother's mother's mother's mother going
back to another continent
so assimilation works but religion stays
and I you know right now we're in a
we're in a period where there's a lot of
you know evangelization and people are
changing religion and things but
religion does have a durability okay and
and Islam right now is a kind of hot
religion it's a religion that is heavily
evangelized it's got a lot of really
fervent
believers and here's the difference that
we've never had it's a religion that in
several parts of the world is at war
with the West now that doesn't mean that
you know every member of the Muslim
faith in Europe is that at war with the
West but there is a there's a
confrontation between the west and Islam
and and you obviously I mean that
doesn't mean that every Westerner is
that at war with every Islam but this is
a problem that we have never faced in
this society which is a which is a you
know a profound sort of religious
Allegiance that some that may be at odds
with your national Allegiance and if you
look at the difficulty John F Kennedy
had in getting elected in night you know
in 1960 at the hoops he had to jump
through at the speech he had to make in
in Texas at a time when you know his
religion was the largest religion in the
United States I mean I you these these
conflicts are bound to be bigger when
when there there is such you know when
there's not I'm not just talking about
things like the Iraq war I'm talking
about what happened in Toulouse the
other day I mean with the you know with
this guy in the in the bomb year so
that's a you know that's obviously a big
it's a big issue yes so oh you wanted me
to talk about debt breaks all right well
you know I I'm not an economist and
which is why I'm so comfortable talking
about the economy I think to a certain
extent the Brussels Pact to get into the
boring detail of the European rescue the
Brussels pact that was sort of
negotiated in in in December without
Britain and then ratified by 26 of the
European countries in February is a
revisiting of the original
European modus operandi for for doing
fiscal union as I said you know I know
I'm killing you I know it's boring stuff
but good good have a good afternoon
no but but the but the you know as I
said you can't have you know this thing
that economists said you can't have a
currency union without fiscal Union the
Europeans really wanted to do this
without a fiscal union and they figured
if they just converged their budget
targets they would be if they would just
harmonize the budget targets that would
work it didn't work and the and the
imbalances that that that created the
the mess except in Greece but the
imbalances in in in Spain and Ireland
that created the the euro mess were
private sector imbalances they were a
function of money created by by banks of
lent out money not you know so-called
printed money so I don't think this is
going to it's not you know I think a
balanced budget is is a nice thing to
have I think but I don't think that this
is going to solve their problems I guess
so oh yes sir
yes yeah well if I could link that to
the earlier question about the welfare
state I mean I think that one of the
more interesting studies that you're
probably talking about is the one by a
Latina and Glaser you know in which they
have found that these are two Harvard
economists who found that the the the
the the smallness of the American
welfare state is about about half of the
cause of the smallness of it as compared
to European countries is the ethnic
diversity of the of the country that
that people don't feel that they're
giving their money to to to sort of
kindred people and so so if what you say
is right
then there is a if there is an economic
cost to diversity you know there still
may I mean it still may be something you
want to have if you want to have a
diverse society it might be something
worth paying for I wouldn't know how to
measure it and and it's not the kind of
um it's not anything that I tried to
quantify in the book or or or managed to
do I mean I think but I think that the I
mean I guess there's also the Robert
Putnam study on hunkering down or
whatever but yeah that's um that's
that's that's interesting you know when
I was talking about borrowing from the
future I'm talking mostly about you know
about political uncertainty rather than
measurable economic loss but they might
there are circumstances in which they
amount to the same thing yes okay all
right I guess I did say that yeah no no
I mean it does I mean it applies in
certain you know there's certain places
where you can see an overlap like I do
think as I say that the that the the
u.s. model and the French the French
model has something of the u.s. model in
it but I think that most European
countries do not I don't want to go to I
don't don't want to be too firm about
that I don't yeah oh well look I I think
that Islam is a problem I don't link it
to every problem with um with with
immigration you know
yes right I think that
because I think that that you know a
devout a person who takes is Muslim
either I there are two ways to describe
yourself as having a Muslim identity
right you can have you know Muslim
belief you can be a religious believer
and that's not what I think most of this
is about don't think it's about belief I
think it's about identity really this I
think that this identity can be just as
if you have a religious based identity
you can be just as uneasy with someone
else's civic nationalism as you can with
someone else's ethnic or religious
nationalism I I don't think that you
need a rival religion as a as a rival it
can be a rival ideology of any kind do
what you think I
okay lay the question on me again
yeah I I think that that I tried I would
agree with that in that and I and I
think that's that's what I was trying to
say with a slightly different vocabulary
when I when I said that I thought the
United States was content to be a nation
of immigrants rather than you know in a
way that Europe Europeans were not to
have you know large large scale
immigration is consistent with civic
nationalism more than with ethnic
nationalism almost by definition right
yeah yeah well I don't know how it how
it will work you know it that varies
over time and you know know the you know
well let's let's look at let's look at
you know how demographics affect
you know the position of these these
countries you know Italy has got a per
capita debt it's about exactly the same
as ours their their debt to GDP ratio is
about a hundred percent right and so is
ours but we've got we're growing fast
we've got where we've got 320 million
people in the country we'd have 400
million at mid-century mid-century we're
gonna be 25% bigger than we are now
Italy is gonna be about 25% smaller you
know and and I think that that that that
shrinkage is going to be
disproportionately in people of working
age so yeah they're in big trouble now
the question is you know immigration is
a very short term solution to that
because immigrants are mortal - right
they age they require health care they
require pensions and so I mean it's a
very it's a good maybe it's a good
short-term stopgap but it's only going
to help you in an absolute way if you
assume they're all going to go back to
their homelands before they retire which
is unlikely right bring in young ones
okay but they're in their dependents too
you know there's an there's an
interesting thing that happens when when
people stop having children is that they
get an they get an actual increment in
their arm they get a boost in their
disposable income because they're not
paying for for children so it's not you
know the the the Europe is not about to
have a comedown from its sort of steady
state you know spending habits it's it's
got a bit of a bonus I mean so it's the
the landing is going to be even harder
than it would ordinarily be you know
I don't think so I don't think no I
don't think because I don't think
they've got a lot of young people for
now which means but I mean that just
means they'll have a lot of old people
and you know in in quicker than you
realize you know it's funny how quickly
you move from the beginning of your
career to to the end of it but you know
but there's another thing I would say
about Turkey which is that it's you know
turkeys produce some terrific economists
it's record of of emerging from
bankruptcy which is what about 12 years
ago it's done it's done a good job in
the last 10 or 12 years nonetheless its
state accounts are not perfectly
transparent and I think that the
experience of the Europe has had with
the imperfectly transparent records in
Greece is probably hurting not helping
turkeys chances of getting in